hello everyone thank you for joining
so
I hope that
everybody is okay we will uh start in
about five minutes
uh at five Israel time
I hope that there are some people who
are joining from Haifa if you are I'm
really
uh happy to welcome you
so just to get uh your expectations
what's waiting for you today so that
everybody is on the same page uh we're
going to do really a Hands-On uh
workshop on RNA sequencing
uh which will include how to search for
data on ncbi how to import the data into
the platform the T bio info platform
uh how to do the analysis of reads and
get the expression table and afterwards
the statistical analysis of differential
expression
um
so hopefully everybody has an account on
the t-buy info because if you don't have
an account
um it might be a bit of a waste of time
if you have any questions regarding
accounts and running pipelines
in the chat
there is an email that you can use
to ask for help
so we will start in just about a few
minutes more we'll wait for people who
are joining
and then we'll start
hi everyone
thank you for joining
um my name is Julia banov I'm an
associate director of talbra
bioinformatics research Center at
University of Haifa
um I'm really excited to welcome you
here and I hope that everybody will be
able to uh
learn today and to use the platform
uh so let me start sharing my slides
um so
the
so our plan for today is uh go something
like this uh we will talk a little bit
about uh sequencing technology
especially Illumina which types of uh
files you will get from the sequencing
facility
uh then uh we will talk about major
steps of analysis or what you can do
with these files
and then uh we will also speak about
finding uh public domain data on ncbi uh
how to find this data and we will use
one of the uh
one of the
um
projects or data sets on ncbi as a
example project so we will download this
uh
uh this data and we will actually run
the pipelines uh so while we will do
this we will also know how to get into
the tbio info how to start running your
pipelines how to get the results what
you should be expecting from the
pipeline
uh and finally we will talk a little bit
about statistical analysis of the
expression table uh in particular
differential expression analysis and uh
files that you can get from there and
also a dashboard that will present all
the graphical uh
graphs and all the tables that can be uh
used for publication if you're thinking
about publication or to uh
or to uh share it with your
collaborators or somebody who you uh
want to share your data with and finally
we'll speak a little bit about the
biological conclusions and how you might
start thinking about uh the results of
this type of a pipeline
um just a quick uh question
um about uh
if you don't have an access to the t-bio
info platform and you would like to run
pipelines together with us please write
in the chat we will try to uh help you
uh
okay
so uh about uh
about the sequencing today we will talk
about one particular type of sequencing
and New Generation sequencing uh usually
done on Illumina machines so on the left
you see the library preparation step
where you have either genomic DNA or
mRNA sequences which are then fragmented
or cut into small pieces and adapters
are
added to these sequences and this is
called a sequencing library now uh after
the library preparation the individual
cdna molecules are clustered on the flow
cell you can see it here on the
cluster amplification graph
uh for sequencing biosynthesis uh where
fluorescently labeled nucleotides are
attached uh and each round of sequencing
the glowing the growing DNA strand is uh
imaged to detect uh which of the four
fluorescence nucleotides has been
Incorporated so you generate weeds of
about from 50 to 500 base pair usually
they can be either single cell single
end so we are reading from one end or a
pair and reads which means we're reading
from two ends
um sorry I missed the slide so this is
uh incorporating uh the fluorescent
labeled nucleotides uh into the Reeds
and then uh sequencing or reading so
what you get as a result of this uh
sequencing procedure is a fast U file
which uh looks uh which has four uh
basic lines for each read uh you have a
read identifier the actual sequence of
the read then some separator line which
is not important and then the base
quality and the base quality can be
important for uh further data analysis
because that's how you know uh how to uh
clean your reads from bad quality reads
for example
um
so the basic steps of uh analysis
include quality control of the reads uh
then after the quality control is done
then there is alignment on some
reference it can be either uh
it can be either uh
genome or a transcriptome
um
and we will talk about uh the difference
uh in a little bit and then
quantification of expression and finally
uh statistical analysis so just a little
bit about each step of the analysis so
in the quality control of reads what
you're trying to do is to eliminate
adapter sequences
and filter out reads with a low quality
scores as we said each read has some
quality assign each nucleotide in a reed
has some quality assigned to it so you
can filter out
parts of the reads or whole reads which
have low quality
alignment on the reference as we said
can be done uh in two ways you can
either align your reads to
um so to uh transcriptal
which means of course that each transfer
uh here denoted by this blue uh
graph has uh exons that this transcript
has so our re and of course these
transcripts are known and they can be
obtained in a something called gtf file
and we align uh pair and reads which are
denoted here by uh yellow and blue so
yellow is a first read first pair and
the blue is the second pair which is Red
from the other side and they are in
between them there is some a gap which
is actually not sequenced and the
alignment then is just putting these
reads in a puzzle way onto these many
transcripts
uh on alternative to this uh is
alignment on the genome so the genome is
of course a whole genome of the organism
which includes exons and neutrons here
exons are uh denoted by Blue
um
blue squares and introns are denoted by
black lines and uh Gene one is denoted
by Blue and Gene 2 is denoted by Green
so here we align our reads uh to these
to the whole genome and what we're
actually interested in to identify uh
differentially
spliced transcripts are these reads that
cover many exons two exons something
that we call a junction so these reads
will be most informative for us because
they will point to the splice variance
if there are any
and uh really uh so uh the
quantification of expression then is
just measuring how many reads align to a
gene this is quite uh simplistic of
course way of uh
uh of a
of um
saying what is the quantification of
expression because of course each gene
or each transcript has its own length
and there are uh quite sophisticated
algorithms that perform this
quantification but for our uh
understanding it is uh helpful sometimes
to think of it as a
um just how many reads align to each
gene
and of course statistical analysis uh
today we will talk only about uh one way
of analyzing our data which is uh
comparing uh expression of each gene in
group one and group two and we will use
a particular algorithm uh golden
standard which is called desect
so uh this is all nice and fine when you
uh have uh your own project and you have
your funding and you can sequence uh
your own project and but sometimes uh
the sequencing is not possible because
of uh there is no funding or maybe you
already found some interesting uh
it's a molecular mechanism in one in
your own data and you want to check in
other models of uh similar to your model
for example whether this molecular
mechanism is really active so many times
we can look for publicly available data
and most most of the data sets today
need to be published to be need to be
uploaded to ncbi database before they
can be published so this is really a
good place where you can start looking
for a public domain data and uh
so
uh
so here I found one of these public
domain uh data sets
and I'm a neuroscientist so I'm
interested in uh in brain and brain
development and neurological conditions
uh so I chose uh
uh project related to my field of study
but of course uh NC by data set
uh database has many many different
types of data it includes RNA sequencing
whole genome sequencing exome sequencing
uh sometimes protonomics data sets uh
you know DNA methylation data sets uh
yes please I think you can just uh
speak
I mean we're not a lot of people so if
anybody would like to
[Music]
um
to ask a question I think we will be
okay I was hoping it's going to be a bit
more Interactive did anybody raise a
hand would you like to ask
no okay so uh let me uh for a minute
just share with you the ncbi uh
the ncbi database
uh I need to new share and then I will
just share my screen
okay so if you will uh look for ncbi in
Google uh you will see this page and uh
here you can find uh almost any data
imaginable really uh so for example if
I'm interested in brain scientists in
brain science I could you know in aging
brain I can write aging brain something
like RNA Secret
uh because we are going to analyze RNA
sequencing data of course there are many
other data sets
so as you can see there are 191 uh data
sets related to aging brain so if we
press on this uh
you know there are many many uh data
sets and I chose uh this particular data
set because it's actually quite small
and we could uh quickly understand oh
there is some chat going on
oh uh sorry yes uh I forgot that uh here
uh actually uh the option to speak is
disabled so if you have any uh questions
you can type them in this chat and I'll
try to answer uh maybe I won't pay
attention all the time but I will try to
do my best so is there any specific
computer system specification needed for
rna-seq data analysis well today we are
going uh to uh do the uh
analysis on the t-bioinfo platform which
is a platform that includes also RNA
sequencing data analysis but also many
other uh analysis types of analysis and
Analysis of different types of data
um
so if we uh go to this uh
data set we will end all data sets on
CBI look uh something like this looks
similar
what we have is a small summary of the
uh and of the data set so actually what
was uh done in the experiment sometimes
it is helpful to read these small
summaries to think if this matches uh
you know your particular uh research
interest if this data set is suitable
for you
and it also has the actual files with
the reads so those are the files with
the reads and here many times the
researchers also put already
pre-analyzed uh table sometimes it's uh
here and sometimes it's not so we will
do analysis both of the reads which are
here as well as uh
post-processing of this
of this
data of this table so before uh I
continue I really urge you I will put
this link
uh into our chat and I really urge you
to uh follow me on ncbi if you can open
ncbi on your computer and try to uh uh
download
this uh this table and unzip it so let
me put the site
that's uh
here probably hopefully everybody can
see so uh one table that we will be
using is going to be this table and the
second thing that we will be using is
something that I really want to uh show
you how to uh
how to uh get because of course you
could press on each one of these uh
links uh let's just do this for a minute
so each link actually brings you to uh
to a uh SRA file which is quite large
you could download this file
sometimes this ncbi uh
platform can be a little bit
um confusing but I hope you will be
patient
um
so you could download this file onto
your computer and we need at least four
of these files because our uh this
particular
project which Compares uh brains of
young animals to brains of old animals
um it will take just a lot of memory of
your computer and it will take a long a
long time
to upload all these files so on the
t-buy info platform there is an option
to upload
um
a round table which is provided with
every project on Geo on ncbi platform so
to get this uh
to get this runtable SRA runtable it's
called here we can press in this bio
project link
and uh
and uh it gives us SRA experiments for
experiments so we will press on this
four
and now we can press on the send to as
you can see these four files are here
and we can press here on send two
file
and here we will change to uh
[Music]
sorry sometimes uh this is a bit
confusing let me quickly come back to my
slides I did it uh
yes so uh we pressed on bio project
we present on SRA experiments
and sent to
file and run info let's see if we can
get to run info file and run install
and we can create this file
and just to check what this file
contains uh let's look at this run info
file
so this run info file actually uh
is a format that includes names of our
samples uh not regular names we from
this file we are not going to be able to
tell which samples are from old animals
and which samples are from Young animals
but we can go back to ncbi and check
exactly uh what is the metadata or which
sample is some old animals or from Young
animals it tells us also the average
length of the read so the average length
of the read here is 300 it also the most
important thing for the platform for the
TBI info platform is this link of course
from where the platform actually
downloads all the data so if you are
trying to download this ncbi runtable
make sure that the table you downloaded
includes the please download path
and the another important information is
the library layout that it is paired and
sometimes you might find here uh the
name of the organism which will be the
name of the reference genome that you
are going to align all your reads to so
once we have this SRA info table
on our computer uh let me save it as a
text file so I'll save it to my desktop
and here I will write SRA run info
um
dating brain
and I will save it as a tab delimiter
tab delimited file
uh and now uh
so now I have this table which instead
of uploading my reads every time I will
just upload this table and be able to
run the uh Pipeline on the platform
so let me just
um
come back to my uh presentation can
somebody please write
in which format can you just answer me
if you can see my transitioning from the
presentation
to the uh
to the Google is it visible because I'm
not sure
yes okay great thanks uh okay in which
format should we download it you can uh
download it as a it usually comes the
the file usually comes as a comma
delimited uh file uh so you can download
it into your Excel or into any uh uh
text editor notepad notepad plus plus
whatever you are used to uh
oh uh after Okay so let's go back some
people are having a bit of trouble so
you select so you press on the bio
project
okay and after you press on the bio
project you should see this uh this page
with SRA experiments
okay and when you see this page you
press on this four
and you come to this page
and then you can do send to
and in send two you will have a drop
down uh
uh a drop down
uh tab where you will choose file
run info
and that's where you can either open it
in your Excel or open it in uh in some
text editor like notepad or notepad plus
plus if you're used to it
um
and then uh you can just save it on your
computer as tab delimited uh as a tab to
limit your platform file sorry
so uh now when we have already on our
computer this tab delimited file uh we
will go to the platform and let me share
with you uh the actual uh platform the
platform uh that you uh should be seeing
looks something like this oh sorry
let me just make this smaller and uh
just to uh you know make a small
overview of the platform uh we have
analysis of different types of omics
data so we have analysis of
transcriptomics data which includes uh
bulk RNA sequencing
de novo transcriptome assembly RNA
editing analysis then we have analysis
of genomics data a whole genome
sequencing or exome sequencing then we
have analysis of non-coding repetitive
elements
we also have analysis of mass
spectroscopy uh several of uh sections
dedicated specifically to cancer biology
we also have analysis of single cell and
uh RNA sequencing uh including spatial
single cell analysis and we have this
big section on data mining which
includes supervised analysis uh
unsupervised analysis factor analysis
and uh differential expression and uh we
are going to uh be working with bulk
rna-seq so I'll press on bulk RNA seek
and
um
hopefully you are following on your
computers and you can also uh see so
what we have here is uh
what we have here
I can't make it smaller
uh is a platform that the top part of
the platform is uh dedicated to
uploading of your data and just uh
telling the platform what kind of data
you have and we will go uh over each one
of these in a little bit and uh and the
bottom part of the platform are the
actual algorithms that you will be able
to use
so uh let me just quickly go back to my
slides
uh okay so
[Music]
um
so we are talking about bulk RNA
sequencing and if you go here you will
see this section and the top uh part is
dedicated to uploading of your data and
uh
so uh really in this uh data part we
have four windows that we need we as
users uh need to uh Define so first one
is called type of reference genome and
there are basically in in this platform
there are basically two types one type
is called r model genome gtf which means
that the genome that you want to be your
reference is already on our system and
to check if it is already on our system
you go to organism and you check whether
your organism is already here in the
system if it is uh great that means you
can just continue
I'm sorry that you're lost Samuel uh of
course I will uh you know share all the
uh all my slides I hope they will be
um
understandable but if you can just write
to me where exactly you're lost I might
you know help you out a bit as we go
along because really we're not that many
people and I was hoping that this is
going to be uh a bit interactive so if
you're lost
um you know you can just uh try to write
where exactly you're lost and we'll try
to help you along and so maybe I'll go a
bit
okay if you're not able to register for
the platform uh there is
in our chat there is an email you can
contact uh called support Pine bio let
me uh write it again for everybody who
is not able to register uh you can uh
you know get in touch with them and try
to get yourself registered
uh I hope it works out
so if we'll go a few slides back
um
so if you are registered on the platform
you will and when you enter the platform
you will see uh this interface
and each writing here is a section
dedicated to analysis of some kind of
data and we are working with today we
are working with RNA sequencing data
bulk RNA sequencing data and while I'm
saying this I might as well also tell
you that
if you are thinking about single cell
uh rna-seq or metagenomics there will be
an additional Workshop in a few days
uh on Tuesday that will be dedicated
to analysis of single cell RNA
sequencing and to metagenomics data so
if your research is related to single
cell rna-seq or metagenomics join again
on Tuesday
but today we're doing bulk RNA
sequencing and also this is one of the
easier uh
easier sections to work with uh so it's
going to be I hope quite straightforward
so when you press on this bulk RNA
sequencing
you will see this uh you will see this
interface which is basically divided
into two parts the top part is the data
upload part and the bottom part is the
actual uh are the actual
uh algorithm so in the top where you
need as a user you need to define the
type of data that you have
so here we are asked to First Define the
types of reference genome and there are
basically two types one type is a genome
that is already on our platform
and you can
uh check if it is already on our
platform by uh here you have organisms
so you can just click on this arrow and
you will see which genomes are already
on our platform let me just go back to
the actual platform to uh to show you
how it looks so we are talking about
this type of the genome there are two
types one is Art model
when you press the bulk RNA sequencing
nothing happens
uh it's best to contact the support
[Music]
um
and uh
so I see that uh some of you might not
have registered before so you might not
get uh full access to uh to the platform
but uh
and so you can uh
yeah you can reach out to the support at
Pine bio and they will be uh happy to
help you along
so but if you do have a full access and
you're able to uh
to do this along with us so those are
the two uh those are the possible
genomes that are already on our
um
that are already on our uh platform any
we are going to the project that I chose
is a project with uh Mouse brains so we
are going to choose musculus this is a
genome of the mouse and we have if you
remember in our uh
uh data table we saw that it was pair
end so we will choose pair end
and of course those are fastq files
uh
if for some reason we have on the
platform that most of the genomes are
already there
so uh just yes uh so
most musculus mm-10 is the updated
Genome of most musculus no patches this
is important for genome so uh assembled
genomes are usually assembled into you
know a people try to assemble genes but
some parts of the genome are hard to
assemble for example they have
repetitive sequences so those are known
as the parts that researchers are not
able to assemble into a full chromosome
they don't know exactly where this part
of the genome belongs to to which
chromosome those are called patches
so uh so so mm10 genome has some of
these patches which is fine those are
parts of the genome that were not we're
still not able to assemble and however
sometimes when you're dealing with for
example genomic data whole genome
sequencing data sometimes you want to
skip those patches because uh for
example you're dealing with a lot of
repetitive elements and you want to
actually not disregard these patches so
we also included this no patch genome
uh hopefully this is uh understandable
so if for some reason your genome your
organism that you are uh
that you are working with is actually uh
not here not in our uh
not in this uh list
you can always go on ncbi and download
The genome of your particular organism
and then if you uh if you have for
example this download a genome and
you're working with some exotic animal
uh then you would choose our genome and
you would have the system will ask you
to upload your fast a file which is a
assembly of the genome uh to the system
but we are working with a regular Mouse
so we will stick to this
uh and after uh
after we selected what type of uh data
we actually have we will press this file
upload and there are several uh ways to
upload your data first is of course
upload the files and as we said when we
downloaded the read the file from ncbi
um the read files are big they're uh you
know we saw there on ncbi that it's
about let's go back and see how big they
are so uh this is a 1.9 gigabytes or 2.2
gigabytes so you know uploading it
uh First downloading it to your computer
and then uploading it to the system will
take a lot of time uh so uh sorry we
were in the we were in here so uh an
alternative to this there could be two
alternatives Alternatives first
Alternatives is if you have a link to
the files and this can be an external
link like from SRA you could also get a
link of each file individually and just
write the link here uh or it can be an
internal link meaning that for example
you uh made a sequencing uh in some
sequencing facility and you have a link
to Dropbox
or to our uh system we already put your
data on our system so it's an internal
link so any of these links can work and
another uh possibility is uploading this
ncbi Roundtable which we actually are
going to use because we downloaded this
runtable so we are going to upload it
right here so let's upload it
uh it was on my desktop and it was
called uh
SRI run info aging brain
so I will upload it
here and when it's uploaded I will
submit this file
and the file is submitted and there are
actually two ways of uh analyzing it and
here I have to uh think a little bit
I can just ignore these groups
and uh and if I want a regular
expression table for right now I don't I
don't really know which groups which
sample is
belongs to Old mice which sample belongs
to Young mice I can just skip the groups
or press cancel no groups
and uh continue with on my analysis
alternatively
I already know that I want to do
differential expression analysis so I
need two groups
uh one group of young brains
young brains of mice and the second
group of old brains
and then I would like to do a comparison
uh this is also possible but we are
going today we're going to do it in two
steps the first step will be just
getting the table
and the Second Step will be doing the
differential analysis of this table
separate
so let's for now we'll just cancel no
groups I want
a table which includes all my samples
uh I want to get that
okay great I'm ready to start the actual
analysis
so the obvious choice here is start and
here we are trying to help you along let
me just uh remind you
of the analysis parts
I came back to my presentation because I
uh
so okay sorry about this uh we already
did all this we chose the organism we
chose okay we uploaded and we already
came to here we chose cancel no groups
and we are back to our
uh actually making our pipeline
so just a reminder of the steps of the
announcements
three
as you remember we said that there are
four basic steps there is quality
control of my reads to make sure that
the reads are good quality and you know
you're working with good material just
like in biology you're always checking
that your samples are good quality
before sending them actually to the
sequencing facility the same is true for
here you want to uh
make sure that the data that you're
analyzing is good quality data
next we will do alignment on the
reference genome or transcripts we will
see
next we will quantify the expression
meaning that we will want to see for
each gene how much of this Gene is
expressed in each sample
yes we are going to make sorry I'm
trying to so there is a question in the
chat and Nisar is asking are we going to
make groups in later steps for
differential expression analysis yes of
course we will get to differential
expression analysis I just wanted to
show you
um
you know how to get the expression table
because obviously sometimes you don't
only have two groups you might have a
data series A Time series uh you might
have you know three groups four groups
so it's not always differential
expression analysis so first I I just
divided those two into two parts we will
get the table and then work with the
stable and put uh put the samples into
groups
so yes it's going to happen
um and finally
sorry there's another question Puja is
asking we saved the file as text tab
delimited but the file uploaded is on
the form of SRA not text
no SRA files are the actual uh files let
me check what we uploaded the SRA files
are it's a special format for
um NGS fastq files which is a
compression of this file so we uh we
uploaded a text file uh let's uh quickly
do this again so I will go to areas of
analysis I will go again to bulk RNA
seek we will again choose the relevant
genome we will choose pair ends
and we will upload our file so here we
will upload my file which is in text
format okay so we will upload it in text
format
and submit
so those uh I see what you mean
you mean that these are uh SRA
that's true this is actually just uh the
name of the actual files which will be
uploaded to the uh platform so of course
the platform is not going to upload this
text table that we gave it it will go to
the link that is in the text table and
upload the actual read files that's why
it's asking me to group the actual read
files and not the text table that I gave
it so it's you know smart it knows that
it needs to download according to the
link that provided in the stable it
needs to download the SRA
so that's why you have this SRA files
over here
okay
um
so uh back to uh here uh yes we were
talking about the steps of analysis just
to show you
that these steps of analysis are
actually hidden here and when you are
used to looking at the at our platform
which you will get used to in just a few
times it just takes you know one or two
times to try it on your own and then you
understand that all sections look the
same and they're actually the same at
first it might sound it might look a bit
complicated but actually you will see
that we divide the algorithms into parts
so for example here you have
pre-processing
part of the pla of the algorithms which
means quality assurance or quality
control
then we have
alignment part and Alignment part is
quite hard and this is because you need
to understand as you remember there are
two types of references that you can use
you can use a transcripts as reference
and that is easy and here you see
mapping on transcripts and it's just one
algorithm that you need to choose either
bwa or bow tie two
or sailfish or HTC
but if you want to align and know
um
you know uh splice variants in your data
for example uh
as you know uh transcripts that are
trans okay so as you know probably genes
something that we call genes are
actually nothing biological there is no
biological entity called the G of course
we have you know we have transcripts
that all uh so each gene something that
we call a gene has many transcripts
and uh to demonstrate this we can
actually go uh you know for a minute
and look for some Gene for example I
work with a gene called Ube 3A
and nub3
uh Gene uh we can uh look
this is the name of the gene of course
and there is a gene Table and there is a
transcript table so actually uh this
particular Gene as you can see here has
many different transcripts and uh
and just a minute somebody is asking is
it possible to work directly with gene
expression measurements files from
string tie output and Define own groups
based on gene expression yes of course
we will do this in a few minutes when we
will actually run this table we will
work with already downloaded gene
expression table and we will uh do the
differential gene expression analysis
but I just wanted to say that if you are
familiar with these notations here uh
the squares are exons and there are
introns and of course each transcript is
a collection of exons and introns or a
collection of exons actually so if you
are interested in particular isoform
that might be appearing due to some
disorder
uh then you might want to really align
all your reads on the genome and find
this alternative uh transcripts that are
not available in the gtf file a gtf file
is a file of all known transcripts so
sometimes we know that some disease
causes uh differences in expression of
some transcripts and if you are really
interested into that in that you might
want to consider running a more
complicated uh
a more complicated uh
pipeline that includes alignment on the
genome uh either Exon detection mapping
on Junctions isoform construction
finally uh
assembling your own gtf uh file which
means assembling your own transcripts
that are particular to your data and
then alignment on this new uh
transcripts uh and then finally uh we
get uh an expression table by pointing
to one of the algorithms here so uh and
and then uh down you know statistical
analysis here you have differential
expression and Analysis can be done from
this section
or can be done later on when you already
have your output and we will do the
second option so just to uh go back to
our pipeline that we haven't started to
generate yet so I wanted to just explain
that this uh platform might look uh a
little hard in the beginning but don't
worry you get used to it very very
quickly so first we want to do some
pre-processing and for example
uh traumatic uh so first I need to press
start and we try on each step to explain
to you and give you references to all
the algorithms and tell you you know
suggest some of the pipelines that you
can run
um
so and here we also try to help you
along by lighting up the buttons that
you can uh press so just uh we are at
the pre-processing step and we are going
to run a classic uh algorithm called
trimomatic which helps me uh to get rid
of adapter sequences of reads which are
have bad quality uh bad quality Parts
um and so on
uh there is a question will this lecture
be available as a recording yes I
believe this lecture will be available
as a recording
so we choose a traumatic and uh most in
most algorithms we allow you uh to uh
choose your own parameters but usually
the parameters that are already default
are the ones that are classic and uh you
can just uh use them as default
so uh save next we are going to align
our reads to known transcripts which
means that we are actually only
interested in already known transcripts
and we are not interested in a new uh
transcripts so we are going to do
mapping on transcripts with bow tie
and finally we will uh as as you can see
we only allow you one next step which is
uh to generate the expression table
using again a standard in the field uh
RSM uh algorithm
now it asks us uh in which uh in which
format do we want to have this
expression table uh will it be in uh
read counts expected counts or in fpkim
or in GPM which are internal controls
internal normalization uh ways of
normalizing for example
uh normalizing by the length of the
transcript
and in reality we actually because uh
you can put fpkm here but in reality you
will get both the fpkm file and the raw
read count because raw read count is
important for such algorithms as dsac
Edge R and other statistical methods of
doing a differential expression so it
doesn't really matter then you end this
pipeline please don't forget to save it
for example and once you save your
pipeline it will appear under your
pipelines later so you might as well
save it with a uh you know some name
that will tell you afterwards for
example I will say aging brain
November what are we six
and
and don't forget to run the pipeline
great and it started running
and uh actually this is uh uh a pipeline
that requires a lot of resources
so it's a long pipeline it takes a lot
of resources
uh computationally to align the reads
the almost two Giga bytes of reads for
each sample so it will take a few hours
to actually run of course it does not
run on your computer it runs on a cloud
on our servers so uh you know you you
don't have to wait for it to run you
don't you can just close your computer
and you will get notified by an email
that your pipeline has finished or uh or
you can also uh in a few hours just
check my Pipelines
and of course I'm you know I'm working
with this uh platform a lot so I have a
lot of pipelines but uh this is the one
that we just ran it just started
processing and uploading the data but
you can see that
um
uh that all my pipelines are saved here
and I can always come back to them and
check what I have there so uh
just yesterday I was running the same
pipeline so that I could share it with
you today and we wouldn't have to wait
five hours
so
here's my pipeline that I ran already
and this is how your pipeline if you run
it right now with us this is how your
pipeline will look like uh in a few
hours
uh
sorry this is not how your pipeline will
work in your in a few hours sorry
okay
so uh
so what you will get here are the uh
the following uh output files you can of
course
uh look in all the out this folder which
has all the output files from your uh
from your pipeline this can be a bit
overwhelming I uh have to agree with you
so let's for a minute look at these uh
dashboards over here there are much uh
easier to understand well as you
remember the first thing we did we
wanted is a quality assurance we wanted
to see that our reads are good quality
so we can uh go to the report the
quality report and look at it online
and
and maybe you have seen these files
before these reports before uh there are
two uh very famous algorithms for uh
quality assurance there is a multi-qc
and fast QC
um
so uh here we have each file uh and as
as you remember each uh sample was pair
and Sample so we have two files for each
sample actually and you can see by the
name of the file uh dash one means
end read end one and dash two read and
two and here we see uh the percent of
reads which were duplicates okay we see
the percent of GC
uh
and if we go down or we can uh also see
uh per sequence quality scores uh which
are very good in our case uh there is a
bit of a problem with per based sequence
content you expect the sequence content
to be you know uh randomly distributed
so about 25 percent of all but we can
see that in the beginning of each file
of each read we have about uh 14 maybe a
bit less maybe 10 uh base pairs uh which
have a strange
um
a bit of a strange uh distribution of a
of TC a and G's but this is actually a
regular thing so uh these uh can be uh
excluded from the analysis by uh using
trimomatic which we did
um next we are checking GC content and
our samples seem to be all right another
interesting uh thing to look at is uh
length distribution and as you can see
it's also uh okay most of our reads are
above 150 which is expected because as
you remember uh in the ncbi table we saw
that both ends were 300 so 150 on one
side 150 on the other side
uh next we have uh this uh is an
interesting uh graph which you can uh
really use is over represented sequences
uh so the algorithm actually calculates
how many percent of reads have some uh
uh camera so sequence some short
sequence which is over represented uh in
your data uh this can mean some uh
contamination by uh by some uh technical
sequence that you might want to get rid
of manually later on and of course there
is
um just a minute there's another
question by Ezekiel could you just
mention the recommended percentage for
each parameter is if possible
so what you're looking for really is uh
the parameter uh usually uh this
multi-qc gives you you know warning
signs so for example with duplication
levels it tells you that six out of your
uh samples out of your eight samples
that we had had some problem with
duplication levels and you can see that
actually more than 10 reads the red ones
are the warning sign ones so here you
have each sample and how many reads have
which percent of duplication left so for
example in Sample uh srr
21851086-2 so second end it has more
than 10 reads hasn't have
are duplicated in 40 of the reads
uh more than uh yes sorry uh more than
10 base pairs are represent are
duplicated in 40 of the rules
uh but if you look uh down here
uh
yeah more than 100
uh sequence uh
more than 100 times
so 20 or just a bit less
uh
now in RNA sequencing uh the usual
duplication level uh is about 15 20 that
this is supposed to be an okay
sometimes you get to a larger
duplication levels for example like here
you have 45 percent uh this can you know
can be a red light maybe I should go
back and check uh was if it's my own
data of course I can check what happened
to the state to this uh sample did I do
you know too many PCR amplification uh
uh
um
uh
called amplification uh times did I do
PCR amplification too much did I change
for example uh
my technician was changed at some point
uh then you know we call it different
hands the different hands make this
sequencing my library of this particular
uh sample but this of course is only
possible if it is your data and you know
how it was processed and you know
exactly what you did many times if
you're working with a
public domain data you have you work
with you know you work with what you
have so uh you it is in reality for
duplication for example in RNA
sequencing it's not advisable to try to
clean it out
so there are a lot of Articles uh
arguing for and against
uh cleaning out duplicates uh some argue
that it is better to clean out uh
duplicate some Market that it's not
better I recommend you know if you have
very high duplication levels to check
both
to try analysis without duplication
duplicate reads to try analysis with
duplicate reads will you get the same
results which results make more sense
and so on
um
but really uh what you have control over
is those over-represented sequences if
we would get here a lot of samples with
very high percent of
over-representative sequences we could
say okay something is wrong with our
reads they are contaminated by some uh
by some technical noise we could try to
clean this technical noise out and of
course if you have a high uh percentage
of adaptive content this is easy to fix
by using trimatic we can always cut
adapters and traumatic already has a lot
of uh you know known and standard
adapters for
Illumina and other machines
um already in its database so it checks
if the uh these adapters are present in
your reads and Millions them out if you
know sorry if you know which adapters
you have been using of course manually
you can also tell thermomatic also on
our platform which adapters exactly you
want to clean out and you will be able
to do that
so uh this is a little bit about looking
at the quality of your reads and it
looks like our reads are okay we can
also look at this other graphs and see
what they uh say about our our samples
here what you see is a box plot of gene
expression overall gene expression in
our samples and we have four samples as
you remember here the uh first read and
the second read are combined and what we
are uh seeing here is that actually our
average expression levels are pretty
much uh similar in both the old uh
brains and the young brains which means
that the distribution of reads is quite
similar and we don't have to worry about
you know uh these samples having very
very different distribution uh of
expression levels
so uh
uh so uh what we actually uh want to uh
download is our main expression table
and uh there are many uh here in the
down uh download folder there are many
types of expression table first of all
uh there's gene expression table and
isoform expression table and we provide
expression tables in FP higher
and in raw reads we will down the
download the raw reads expression table
because uh raw read expression table
will be used further on for differential
expression analysis where we will run in
a separate different section so
um
like so another interesting uh table
here is this mapping stats table let me
just for a minute uh show it to you
so this table actually tells you how
many of your reads were successfully
aligned to the reference and we see that
uh
I opened it in a
[Music]
in notepad but it's of course easier to
look
in Excel so just put it for you in Excel
so each two columns are dedicated to one
sample and you can see here the name of
the sample here you see
how many reads were in each sample and
you can see percentages okay so this is
one sample let me just divide it for you
uh quickly so that it will be easier to
look
so each two columns are one sample
uh so for example in this sample uh zero
eight five
overall about 80 percent of reads were
successfully aligned uh to our reference
and remember that we uh aligned our
reads to transcripts to known
transcripts so this uh alignment
percentage is quite well is quite good
and uh you know if you would get
something like 15
or 20 of your reads aligning
successfully to your transcript it can
mean two things uh or you've
can mean different problems one problem
could be that you know you're using a
reference that is wrong so for example
you actually have a data set from human
brain but you're trying to align it to a
mouse genome and then you know a lot of
reads get uh missed out
are not aligned and that's one positive
another possibility is that you're
working with non-model organisms
um that the genome is not well annotated
you don't have a lot of well annotated
transcripts so again a lot of reads come
from transcripts that are not in your uh
uh in this gtf file that's another
possibility a third possibility could be
that you have a great contamination you
know if you were uh dealing with a
sample that uh got contaminated by some
bacteria uh then most of the Reeds can
come from bacteria or in yeast or uh
virus and not come from the actual
organism that you're trying to uh
um to analyze so this is this uh table
can also be helpful in trying to
understand if your data is okay if your
pipeline was okay if everything if you
can continue with that uh with that
house
okay back to our uh platform
and back to our download folder where we
have
um
where we have uh okay so where we have
all the tables
uh we're working on organizing The
Stables in a more comprehensible way but
what you uh can see here for example is
expression of genes if you look at the
uh end of the name of this file you will
look you will see expression genes fpkm
so you can download these this file and
look at the expression in fpkm but what
we're really interested in right now is
expression of genes uh just expression
of genes which means that those are uh
read counts and it's important that
these are read counts because
gsec algorithm HR algorithm and all
differential expression algorithm
algorithms uh use raw recounts because
they do normalization inside the
algorithm itself
so we will save the link
and uh and I put it in my folder for
aging brain
okay it opened it great
and
um
let me just show you to you
in Excel again format and it will be
easier to see
what we have here
so what we have here is as follows we
have four samples
which are columns
uh the names of the samples are here let
me just make it it's wider yes
okay
uh and uh here on the first uh column
are my Ensemble uh Gene names which is a
special code for the gene name uh in the
download folder
if we'll go back to our
download folder with a lot of uh
a lot of
files we will also see a files that in
the end is written with annotation so
let's also save this as a link because
it will give us uh so as you can see
here you can also okay let me also bring
this into a cell file
so that it will be
better visible
okay
so here I will put the with annotation
as you can see with annotation file has
uh some
annotation of this uh Gene name of this
Ensemble symbol for for the ones that uh
that are known some of the uh ensembles
symbols are not identified by a official
Gene symbol so we just
but what is known about it you know
either it's protein codeine or
non-coding for the ones that you have
ensembled official uh Gene symbol you
can see this Gene symbol uh here uh
scml2 and so on so
it doesn't really uh matter which table
uh you use I like to use uh sorry our
raw table with no annotation because
later algorithms like dsec and HR
uh give us official name symbols and do
enrichment analysis and so on and we
will uh do this in just a minute what I
wanted to uh show you is that uh the
output file has all the samples that we
ran with the expression
the expression here is in raw read
counts
so now this table can be uh further
analyzed on the
on the platform
so we will go again to the areas of
analysis
and there are two options first option
is that as we did together you will run
bulk RNA sequencing and you will get
this table of expressions in raw read
counts and you have it on your computer
and now you're ready to do differential
expressions
that's uh that's the first option the
second option as we saw in uh ncbi
let me go for a minute to ncbi
in our particular uh uh in our
particular project that we are analyzing
I'll go back a bit uh we had this table
that the researchers who uploaded the
data into this uh
database
they uploaded it already with the read
counts
and you can download this table to your
computer uh if you wish or if you're
working with you know your own if you
want to do your own
uh project and Analysis uh you can
either do you know
computationally expensive
analysis of raw reads
align them to the reference get the
table and do uh analysis of a
differential expression analysis or any
other statistical analysis machine
learning and other analysis that are
available on the on the platform
or you can go straight to downloading
this uh file supplementary file which is
many times available
uh and use this for a differential
expression analysis
anybody has a question and you can type
the question uh if you if if something
is unclear you can just type the
question I try to look at all the
questions and answer them in uh real
time
hopefully it's helpful
uh okay so back to our uh platform let's
imagine that we downloaded this uh
this file and uh let's download it
really so that uh we are doing it
together hopefully you can go back to
our ncbi page and download it together
with me
and I will save it
somebody is unmuted
so uh if you're unmuted
um
then you can
either ask a question in the chat
[Music]
and that's probably the best way to go
so
um
so I uh have this I downloaded uh this
file
um and now I will
um
I will copy it
to my folder
where I'm actually keeping all my
data for today's Workshop
okay it is uh zipped so you'll have to
unzip it I have
extract once
okay and if you go there is our file
let's look at it is it
similar to what we had in the past and
let's check
so uh
several things that
[Music]
um
that are important to remember uh when
using a differential expression
uh to use differential expression your
table
with every algorithm it's like this your
table has to be in a particular format
and the format has to be as well
make sure that you only have one column
of IDs
it can be either Ensemble IDs or Gene
name IDs doesn't matter but it has to be
one call okay so uh let's
stick with Gene names just because uh
just because
a lot of biologists like Gene names
because they're more understandable than
these Ensemble IDs so we will delete
The Ensemble IDs
next we check
that there are no uh
spaces in the names of your samples
so to do this it's very easy in Excel
and you can just do replace
space
with for example underscore
and I'll do replace all
and I see that there were actually a lot
of spaces in my names so I uh corrected
this problem and the final uh thing to
just check in your table is that you
don't have any Gene names that are
repeated
sometimes to Ensemble IDs have the same
gene symbol this is actually uh quite
quite often it happens so uh
so to uh eliminate this problem
we'll just uh we'll just make sure that
there are no uh Gene names that are
repeated so I go to data in Excel
remove duplicates
by column A so by my G names
and as you can see here I had 11
duplicated values which means if I would
not check that probably my algorithm
would fall and tell me to do it so it's
good that we checked
finally we have to uh save our file as
tab delimited
so
file
save as
and I'll just save it here together with
our
app to Limited
green expression
aging
brain
right
and whenever you have your own project
and you would like to download data from
ncbi just check these simple steps and I
have it actually in my uh presentation
so anybody who lost me at some point
sorry about this uh let me just open my
presentation again
50 minutes
ah now which is complicated uh okay
okay open my
presentation we're almost there
so we just talked about the output table
and here are the rules
the rules of the input table format
sure uh first
columns are your samples make sure that
you have that
lines are your features either genes or
transcripts
First Column is the J names or gen
symbols or whatever ID you have for your
name but just make sure that it's just
one column
there are no duplicate Gene IDs so make
sure that you get rid of all the
duplicates
there are no spaces in the names of the
samples
so also get rid of all the
[Music]
um
all the spaces
uh it's a very desirable to uh look at
your data that you have no missing
values because of course if you have uh
[Music]
uh
if you have some missing values uh the
algorithm most probably will not work
and finally that the table is in tab
delimited format in txt format and now
we're ready for uh inputting this table
two differential Expressions section of
our plot let's go to our platform
as you might remember
oh sorry
no like this I cannot see it at all I
need to be able to see the chat
okay
um
one message
yes we have not checked for missing
values this takes uh in Excel a bit more
time
um so uh you know you could uh in Excel
the easiest way I think to do it would
be adjust to if you don't have too many
samples uh just to do a filter
did you filter
and you check that there are no NHS
you see there are no Nas here
no one is here
no and A's here and no and A's here
and
um so this is a very easy way of
checking your uh missing values in uh
in Excel
um so
um okay that was that uh yes we were at
the platform
so in the platform we are going now to
use this table uh to do differential
expression analysis so we will go to
this data mining section of the platform
and press on differential expression
and we get to a graph that is built
similarly so we have a top part of the
graph
uh just a minute there is a question
uh from yaren uh are the repeated Gene
names have the same numeric value in
other columns
ah I see what you mean you're saying
probably correct me if I'm wrong you're
saying okay but we got rid of some of
the uh
lines that had repeated Gene names as
some other Lines line in my table
uh I don't know what I erased
correct that's what you're asking how do
you know that they have they are exactly
the same so yes you are absolutely right
that's why I like to not go to Gene uh
official Gene name because that makes a
lot of genes seem the same but better to
go to Ensemble names Ensemble names
almost never repeat I mean never really
so if we would uh get rid of the gene uh
name we wouldn't have this problem at
all but we decided to make it you know
easier to biologists because a lot of
biologists are just used to names uh
official Gene names uh so it's easier to
look at tables like this
but a lot of Ensemble symbols Ensemble
uh codes have similar Gene name they are
not this actually the same genes this is
important to know so maybe we got rid of
11 duplicates so that means that we
might be wrong about 11 genes
uh from about let's see how big our
table is it's a should be about uh 15 to
20
000 uh let me check
it is uh 19 500 genes so we you know we
might be mistaken about 11 genes out of
20 000 genes I think we could be
forgiven
um but of course if you are uh very
meticulate about it you know you should
use probably Ensemble
um Ensemble numbers and not these genes
uh
uh okay so back to our platform
you're welcome
um
again the the platform I hope you are
getting used to uh the way the platform
looks it usually we try to keep it you
know consistential across all the uh
the sections so we have file upload
above and we will upload our file and we
try to make it you know really bold
please use raw read counts it's
important because a lot of people try to
uh use fpkm or TPM uh
accounts and gsec and Edge our
algorithms don't work well with these
they have internal normalization uh
which really uh it's not just uh it's
not good to use with uh gsec so
we will upload our data I have it online
computer
and it's
gene expression aging brain that we just
did and when it uploads I will select
the groups and here I have no option not
to select because this is differential
expression this section is dedicated to
analysis of two groups so uh in my uh
table
that we downloaded from ncbi there were
actual names
uh of the samples so it's really easy to
recognize which sample belongs to which
group so I will put week 70 as an older
group uh in group b and the young
five-day group uh in uh group a
sometimes uh as we saw in our when we
ran our own uh samples uh earlier on you
saw that actually each sample had a name
with srr something something some
numbers so uh if you are not sure what
your groups are you can go back to ncbi
and check uh you know which srr file
belongs to which group which is old uh
brain which is young brain so just make
sure you know before you actually run
this pipeline uh so we submit our data
and now the pipeline here is very simple
uh first we uh start and again we try to
explain all the steps and guide you
along the two uh really classical
algorithms for differential expression
are either gsec2 or HR and dsac in
recent years has become more and more
popular so we will also use dsac and
here we have uh several parameters that
let's just read through and make sure
that everything is understandable by the
way if some parameter you are not sure
about you can always stand on this I
icon and we try to explain what this
parameter actually means
um so this particular parameter is
account filter for dsec it means that if
the gene has all uh uh expression values
less than this number uh then we will
throw this Gene out
um next parameter is about volcano plot
hopefully you have seen enough of the
bioinformatics Articles and you are
familiar with this very popular volcano
plot where on uh you on the x-axis you
have uh log full change and on the
y-axis you have uh p-value if you're not
familiar with it don't worry
in a few times that you run this
pipeline you will be very familiar with
this and we will look at this volcano
plot in just a minute but uh this uh
threshold uh is just what is the
threshold of log full change so that my
genes will be
um
uh identified as a differentially
expressed so if a gene is twice has an
expression level twice as big in one
group than in the other
uh then I want it to be differential
expressed and here is the threshold for
the p-value again which genes will be
identified as differentially expressed
and finally uh it's asking me which
database should should we use should we
use a human database or a mouse database
uh and we will use the mouse database
because this is the genome we are
working sometimes you are working with
an organism that is not here it's not a
mouse and it's not a human
uh it happens a lot of times
uh the differential sorry the
differential expression doesn't really
rely on any database but the gene
ontology terms that we will look at in a
in just two minutes uh will of course
rely on some database to put the genes
in some you know biological Pathways or
biological ontology terms and so so that
you can interpret them functionally
and a lot of times uh for a lot of
organisms these are not available so
many researchers use either mouse or
human
databases to build these uh pathways
um
so of course some Gene ontology
databases are also available for
non-model organisms
uh so you know you might want to check
and if you find something and you really
want to use this Gene ontology database
you can reach out to us and we will try
to put it here as well
and finally we would like to do uh
something that is called functional
enrichment analysis this is uh this is
this pathway analysis putting our
differentially expressed genes into
known pathways
um
and here it asks us again which genes do
you consider differentially expressed
for these pathway analysis and again you
can play around with these uh with these
parameters but uh usually these
parameters are just fine uh as default
and I I will not run genes uh in gsea
analysis but you can try it uh later on
if you would like so
um it's just an alternative to
differential expression analysis an
alternative way to analyze uh your data
and here again I will uh write something
like aging
brain and D sec
and and run my bike don't forget to run
your partner
sorry
I'm sorry this is taking uh so long I
uh we should be finished in just about
15 minutes
this pipeline
doesn't take uh that much resources it
will be over in about uh 15 minutes 15
to 20 minutes but I will not wait for it
I ran this pipeline before so I also
already have it here
from today
uh and again uh we have the output files
uh in download folder you can uh look at
all these files there are PDFs there are
uh all the tables that you need but
luckily for us we also have this
something that we call external
dashboard
and uh external dashboard uh is our you
know quite new uh addition to the
platform where we make available all the
uh tables and all the graphs uh
in uh
in a shareable format so actually now uh
even if you did not have uh access to
the platform and couldn't run
uh the plot the pipeline with us let me
share with you the dashboard so you can
also look at the dashboard together with
us and uh the same in a similar way that
you would uh you know share it with your
collaborators uh or go back to the same
link and uh look at it again
so what do we have in this dashboard
first of all we have the very famous
volcano plot
where in red are the genes that are
differentially expressed uh sorry there
is a uh a question
uh how did you get the corresponding log
P values for each gene I think I missed
that part can you please explain well uh
this is actually done by this dsec
algorithm so what dsec algorithm does it
calculates the uh the p-values of
differentially expressed genes and the
log flow changes so uh so you put in uh
our expression table
as as you remember with all the genes
in a minute with all the genes and just
the raw expression expression values and
we uh ran this algorithm uh which is
called gsec
and this uh
D SEC algorithm uh you can imagine it as
something similar to t-test it has
internal uh normalization of your table
and it calculates how different uh your
Gene is expressed in the two groups that
we assigned uh so this is the what
desect is then so it gives you a table
with uh P values and with log flow
changes and normalized counts and if you
want to see this table it is actually
right here uh in the zip file if you
will download the zip file you will see
a table
uh this is one way of looking at the
table another way of looking at the
table is now going to our dashboard and
there is a tab called table you can go
to this tab
and you can download a desec table
and this is uh the table let me
sorry about the format
let me just
bring it all to
Excel
no
okay no problem right here
okay let's go back to the table
sorry about this so uh you can download
the table and look at it uh on your
computer but you can also look at the
table right here this is the output of
the dsec algorithm and what you have
here are our uh
names of the uh genes and uh if you look
closely
I'm sorry if this is
not very visible hopefully this will
make it better so uh you have Elias
which means that if for example I would
use my Ensemble uh ID then here would be
my assemble and here would be my uh
symbol of the Gene and here's some Gene
name the actual G name finally log 2
full change and p-value including
adjusted p-value and some annotation of
this Gene so uh here it's very easy to
see which genes are differentially
expressed
uh and on the dashboard
we have uh volcano plot where you can
interactively change the thresholds
either for uh full change you know we
said right now we're working with uh uh
two times the expression uh or uh or
with p-value you can uh so here you can
have uh change the uh
the log full change here you can change
the p-value uh and you can see how many
are of the genes are up regulated how
many of the genes are down regulated and
in our particular case this is just a
great data set you know with lots and
lots of uh genes that are differentially
expressed
uh on the right side you have uh
[Music]
a heat map
I just have to put it somewhere so I can
see if somebody is asking
um
a heat map again let me make it a bit
bigger uh in the heat map you can see uh
the for example you can change the
number of genes that are differentially
expressed you can also uh change whether
your uh identifying your G's by uh
p-value or by adjusted p-value and you
can see if the gene is uh upregulated or
down regulated in uh in Old brain so our
group number two
um
can you please uh let me know if you can
all follow me on this dashboard if it
opens for you and you can actually see
the link and that will be really good
um
yes great okay and uh finally on the
bottom uh you can see uh you can choose
uh genes that are of your interest for
example I might be interested in caspase
3 so I will add uh you know this Gene
and see that it is up regulated in my uh
so you might not see my
yeah it is uh up regulated in uh
prenatal uh brain and down regulated in
uh older brain
um
next
tab on the uh on this
um dashboard is the enrichment analysis
and enrichment analysis uh allows us to
really uh
um
uh enrichment analysis allows us to
understand the function of these genes
as you saw we have so many genes
upregulated and down regulated in our
old brain that it's uh makes it really
hard to understand what is the
functional meaning of all these genes so
uh
functional enrichment analysis combines
these differential we expressed genes
into known Pathways or known what we
call Gene autology terms so if we look
closely on the left we have Gene
ontology terms
um
and we can see uh so the size of the
circle means how many genes from my
differentially expressed genes are
actually uh
are in the list of this particular uh
pathway or genotology term and the color
of the uh
the color of this uh Circle means the
p-value or adjusted p-value of the
enrichment not of the actual Gene but
the of the enrichment how uh definite am
I when I'm saying that this pathway is
enriched by uh by my differential
Express genes so if I look here I see
that mitochondria is uh differentially
expressed which might make sense we know
that in uh older brain mitochondrial
functioning
uh is disrupted uh and uh other you know
ontology terms that might be helpful to
understand better what's going on in my
data another way is uh keg uh Pathways
again uh those are known Pathways and
genes that are
expressed in these known pathways
and finally in the table you can
download
uh
one question hi uh prasika uh you're new
to bioinformatics these terms are
somewhat new how to understand this uh
yes I understand this can sound
overwhelming Gene ontology and Pathways
this is uh less related to
bioinformatics I would say this is more
related to biology so if you know uh in
uh we have
these uh databases that have been
assembled by a lot of researchers all
over the world and we know from uh a lot
of experiments which combine genes into
functional uh assemblies so they are a
number of genes that are known to work
together and to have some uh biological
means some function or some pathway for
example apoptosis you probably heard of
this pathway uh and uh apoptosis as a
functional pathway is of course done by
individual genes and uh we can
throughout the years of many studies all
over the world we know which genes are
involved in uppercutives so we can
uh give uh to each gene that is involved
in apoptosis this uh
this Mark
uh that it is uh involved in Apocalypse
and that's how we know which uh pathways
are differentially expressed
I hope that was uh somewhat uh
understandable if not uh you're welcome
to you know go on Google and write a
gene ontology terms and there is a whole
lot of literature on how these ontology
terms have been developed over the time
how we uh we are still working on them
not all genes are known uh how they work
together so this is you know work in
progress of the whole Community Life
Sciences community so
um there was another question
uh from uh
smriti uh I didn't get the significance
of volcano plot is it just a quick
visualization at thousands of genes and
to know What proportion of those are up
or down regulated you're exactly right
so let's go back uh to the volcano plot
volcano plot on its x-axis
what you see are log 2 full change which
means uh you know if you uh if you have
so uh let's calculate uh manually the
fold uh log full change so that
everybody's on the same page so uh
Works similarly to t-test I hope that
everybody knows how to run t-test in
Excel
of course this is just you know this is
not the right way to do it our data is
not normalized that we're looking at
right now uh so but this is just an
example of how you would uh how to
understand and interpret p-values and
log 2 full changes so um
because dsac has you know a complicated
way of calculating the differences
between averages in one group and
another group we will not I can't show
you in Excel how to run dsec but I can
show you uh an easier version student
t-test uh hopefully you're familiar with
it if you're not familiar with it go
back and uh you know just kind of
freshen up on your statistic basic
statistics
uh but uh let's have this column we call
it we'll call it t-test
in Excel it's very easy what t-test
actually does is compares the averages
in these two I will color them
those are our groups okay the pink one
and the green one uh so it's compares
the averages the average expression of
each gene in pin group compared to Green
group okay and we will write in it so
it's very easy equals t-test
average this
this
we will do two-tailed distribution
and
um
tails
and we will do uh unequal variance okay
if you are not familiar with these terms
about t-test I really urge you to go and
freshen up on your statistics it will
take about you know a couple of minutes
so uh
what we have here are the actual uh
t-test p-values
wait just a minute there are people who
are uh
let me answer the question real quick
so haseeb is asking in gene expression
analysis sometimes we get multiple log
full change values of the same gene in a
single sample
do we have to take an average in this
case
um
foreign
actually a wrongful change we are going
to do it right now but it's always a
comparison between averages so there is
a
you can't get multiple times so uh let
me just continue for a minute I hope it
will be more clear so what we just did
here in Excel is the t-test p-value
and it is you know similar to the
p-value we see in the dashboard so this
would be something like a p-value this
is how significant significant is the
difference between uh averages uh for
this particular Gene
now if we want to uh do uh fold change
um and I'm leaving just log
for a minute alone I'm going to do fold
changes because what I'm working with
are just expression tables they have not
been uh
recalculated into a logs logarithmic
scale if if I would have a table in
logarithmic scale then I would right
away work with log full changes but I'm
working just with spoken just what it
basically means is the difference
between averages so I will calculate the
average
uh equals average
of my group
pink of my pink group
okay divided by the average
of my green green group
and this is the full change that you see
well not exactly this is the full change
and then if you take the log
arithm base two
base two
this will be the value
that you see in log 2 full change in our
dashboard well
so uh but of course my table
is not normalized dsec has internal
normalization so your full changes will
be different if you do it in Excel and
if you do it in uh using the algorithm
but this is just to give you an idea of
what this actually means so for example
let's look at Gene uh I will color it in
yellow
uh so uh Gene whatever this Ensemble
uh term means
we don't care right now uh but it is
six uh times so the expression level in
the green group is six times as big as
the expression table
uh in the uh Pink
so now let's go back for a minute to the
volcano plot again what we have on the
x-axis are these log flow changes so you
know the differences between the
averages what we have on the y-axis is
uh minus logarithm of p-value this is to
make this famous volcano plot if I would
plot just p-value uh I would have very
very tiny uh values for all my
significantly differentially expressed
genes here the most significantly
differentially expressed genes are up
are the top dots
so uh because I'm taking minus logger
you can check it in that so if we'll go
back to the Excel
and uh so here as you can see those are
very small values uh those are our P
values okay t-test that's called p p
values
if I want
the minus logarithm of
uh
of the p-value
ah Maxwell doesn't like this minus
okay minus
so in Excel I would do equals minus log
of our p-value base
2 or 10 doesn't matter
it's small it's insignificant
and the larger it is the more
significant it is so for example let's
sort our uh
you got too big
let's sort our P values
from smallest
to largest it will take a bit time as
you can see
small values small p-values become big
in log in minus log P value so that
makes a nice graph over here
uh
uh called Volcano graph hopefully this
is uh now more clear
then if
if we're clear on that can somebody just
uh give me a heads up that we're okay
and we can continue
basically what you see on the next one
on the heat map are uh
are normalized uh values of this of
these genes Z transformed values so that
it is easy to see which ones are which
genes are upregulated which genes are
down regulated so uh you know you can
choose a different number of genes for
example I'm interested in uh I don't
know five
uh most uh differential Express genes
and I see that caspase 3 is let's see
um
is uh up regulated in my uh
in my young male in my young brains down
regulated in Old brains uh and other
genes that I can really uh look to
um
so
um
so this is uh basically uh the end if
you have you know uh
again you can download all the tables
you can study your enrichment analysis
uh and find functionally which uh
functional pathways are uh important in
the Aging of the brain uh hopefully this
was you know beneficial to all who
stayed until the end
um
thank you very much for staying
until the end
if there are
any questions
uh comments
and I'll be happy to answer if you have
any questions regarding access to the
platform you can uh
you can write to the support of fine
biotech
uh if you are joining from Haifa thank
you very much
and uh we will be happy to see you also
in the office if you have any questions
thank you very much for to everybody for
your attention and your patience